-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now we are going
to get to the news.
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
scheduled a last-minute
public hearing for today
with former Trump White House
aide Cassidy Hutchinson,
and it was wild.
We learned that on January 6th,
Trump knew the crowd
had weapons,
that he tried to get
the metal detectors removed
because, quote,
"They're not here to hurt me."
He got mad at Bill Barr
over lunch
and threw a plate
full of ketchup at the wall.
And that when he found out
that his limo
was not going to the Capitol,
he lunged for the throat
of a Secret Service agent
and tried to grab
the steering wheel.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, isn't that unreal?
Who has ketchup at lunch?
[ Laughter ]
President Biden on Saturday
signed the bipartisan
gun safety bill into law.
This news first reported
by a tiny crawl
on the bottom
of your screen.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, President Biden
signed the law --
signed into law the first major
federal gun safety legislation
in nearly three decades --
three decades!
In the time it took you guys
to pass one gun law,
there's been six Batmen.
[ Laughter ]
After the Supreme Court
overturned Roe vs. Wade,
former Vice President Mike Pence
praised the decision
and said in a statement,
quote, "Today, life won."
"Whereas on January 6th,
it was touch-and-go."
[ Laughter ]
After the Supreme Court
overturned Roe vs. Wade
last week,
Dick's Sporting Goods
announced that it will provide
financial support for employees
who need to travel out of state
for abortion access.
Ahh, Dick's --
the problem AND the solution.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The rare case.
The Supreme Court ruled
yesterday
that the First Amendment
protects public school employees
who pray openly.
Alright.
Well, you know
what you got to do,
art teachers.
[ Laughter ]
Counting on you, art teachers.
In an interview after
he was slapped on the back
by an employee of
a Staten Island grocery store,
Rudy Giuliani said
that it felt like, quote,
"Somebody shot me."
Wow. That is...
That is awful.
Let's see the tape.
[ Laughter ]
Do you think that's what
being shot feels like?!
No wonder you're not
concerned about guns.
That wasn't a slap -- that was
a Little League coach saying,
"You'll get 'em next time."
[ Laughter ]
According to New York's MTA,
in the first five months
of this year,
over 400 incidents
were reported of people
riding on top of
or outside subway trains.
In their defense, though.
have you seen
the inside of those trains?
[ Laughter ]
A Norwegian Cruise Line ship
struck an iceberg
over the weekend
while sailing
off the coast of Alaska.
Finally, some good news --
there are still icebergs!
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a Chihuahua mix
named Mr. Happy Face
was recently crowned
the world's ugliest dog.
They knew it was a winner
when the other dogs
started sniffing its face.
[ Laughter ]
Scollins!
That was a monologue, everybody.
We got a great show
for you tonight.